um i
itr is asking has it been all of your
experiences that women
have a man lined up immediately after
breakup is this hard-coded or can it be
controlled
the answer is generally speaking yes
they've done surveys to ask women to
disclose
honestly if they've got a backup plan if
50 of women acknowledge it
the other 50 aren't being honest
acknowledging it because they don't want
to look bad so
generally speaking women you usually
have a back-up plan before they're going
to leave a guy that's even in a
long-term relationship or a marriage
waking up with you she broke up with me
six months prior
oh yeah i don't think that you can call
the undeniability about it though oh he
was just a friend he was just somebody i
knew
possible each other things just happened
i never planned this
but [ __ ] you check the you check the
call logs they're texting for a year
with [ __ ]
you know sexual banter and whatever [ __ ]
just because they are [ __ ] yeah it
doesn't mean that she didn't already
have that guy
but you've been working out with your
personal trainer for the last eight
months what do you mean it just happened
i tell you what too for the guys in the
audience for those of you who have
girlfriends or wives try something
tell her to go on facebook and change
her relationship status it's complicated
and then wait 24 hours yeah then go into
her private messages
i'll leave it there and that's all you
need to know on this
every guy in her life is just waiting
for that chance
he's just sitting there he's in the
lineup they're they're waiting at the
apple store for the new i [ __ ] 5.
[Laughter]
but what's up sterling welcome i met
this guy sterling and he was so cute and
i don't know what happened one thing led
to another and you know
like like you said guys like even if
even if she like
she if she has like a billion options
lined up anyway you know what i mean
like every girl does like every single
male friend
she has is one of those guys who's
waiting to like jump her bones
when you disappear so geez imagine if uh
imagine if one of your girls close
male friends is sterling cooper you
would just be like you're in trouble
breaking it the whole time wouldn't you
look there's no such thing look there's
no such thing as my old friends
yeah they don't exist like it's just
it's like it's like all the girls that i
actually call
friends are girls are girls in my
industry that i've had sex with
yep you know like that i haven't i have
girlfriends
yeah i have girlfriends too but they're
people that i'm having sex with or have
had sex with
or about to
you